oups
[Musique]
j'ai fait une erreur que je vous
explique j'ai publié hier matin une
vidéo sujet du smartphone à écran
pliable de samsung en dix ans samsung a
dévoilé par erreur son smartphone à
écran pliable en erreur erreur
simplement pourquoi je vous explique un
peu l'histoire je rentre de république
dominicaine ya quelques jours ça vous en
faites pas échapper si vous avez regardé
mes vidéos d'avant et sur le retour
qu'est ce que je fais je feuillette là
dessus je regarde un peu ce qui se passe
de quoi je peux vous parler au sujet des
sujets qui m'intéressent et qui je pense
peuvent aussi potentiellement vous
intéresser et je tombe sur un article je
suis plus sur quels médias qui parlent
effectivement d'une publication par
samsung vietnam d'une vidéo justement
dévoilant son smartphone à écran pliable
et qui a retiré très rapidement vidéo
qui a ensuite été reprise republier
voilà donc je me dis ah ça ça
m'intéresse parce que justement ces
smartphones des campings je vous en
parle beaucoup
ils sont tout ce qui m'intéresse
vraiment du coup je prépare ma vidéo et
je la diffuse lundi matin c'est à dire
hier matin c'est à dire ce matin parce
que pour moi je la tourne rond dès lundi
pour vous quand vous la regardez on sera
mardi à lyon fait il sculpte le stick
cérébrale très simple sauf que en
réalité ce que je pensais être une vidéo
qui avait chuté et qui pourrait être
présenté le 20 février lors de la
présentation des samsung galaxy s 10 est
en réalité une pub samsung qui est
présenté sur leur chaîne youtube et qui
tourne en boucle à la télé autant vous
dire que lorsque je tends ma vidéo sur
une fuite
on est loin d'une fuite on est sur un
stock et on a hâte et les doulas grand
serre alors déjà je tiens à m'excuser
auprès de samsung parce qu'effectivement
je me suis planté là dessus je tiens à
m'excuser auprès de vous qui me
suivaient qui nous fait confiance
déconnexion complète très clairement je
me cherche pas d'excusés vous explique
juste déconnexion du fait de partir en
république dominicaine avec un accès
internet très très limité juste pour
pouvoir envoyer quelques vidéos tous les
deux jours du coup pendant dix jours
c'était assez peu au fait de l'actualité
c'est vrai que je ne suis pas replonger
dedans directement du coup kroes
là dessus donc j'en suis très
sincèrement désolé c'est pour cette
raison je préfère vous faire cette vidéo
là comme ça je vous dis les choses je
les publier j'ai twitté j'ai mis sur
facebook j'ai mis en commentaire de la
vidéo d'hier mais voilà je préfère vous
le dire les yeux dans les yeux en tout
cas les yeux dans l'objectif je sais que
d'un autre côté c'est vous qui vont
regarder donc voilà et alors ma part
désolé rassurez vous je dors partent pas
en vacances rapidement donc comme ça je
veux pas trop moi déconnectée j'ai
vraiment rester focus évoqué l'actualité
alors on va reparler un petit peu de
cette vidéo parce qu'elle est assez
intéressante justement nicolas louche de
01net me faisait remarquer sur twitter
il a raison c'est une suite de concept
en fait une suite de concept mais au
milieu de cette suite de concept on voit
un produit qui va sortir très
prochainement c'est ce fameux smartphone
à écran pliable
alors si vous regardez l'image que vous
avez sur la vidéo sur le spot télé qui
tourne en ce moment est le produit qui
était présenté par samsung leur
conférence des développeurs
il ya effectivement une vraie différence
visuelle à 13.8 était un proto pas
complètement terminée donc on verra un
peu l'aspect final qu'il aura donc on ne
sait pas réellement à quoi va ressembler
ce smartphone à écran pliable à ce
moment là mais néanmoins vous l'avez
tout au début de la vidéo il ya écrit
que ce sont des concepts pour illustrer
la vidéo et qu'effectivement ce ne sont
pas des produits finis tels que pointent
les retrouver chez nous probablement
d'ici quelques années
il ya en tout cas pour le smartphone à
écran pliable d'ici quelques semaines
voire quelques mois un smartphone en
tout cas que j'attends avec impatience
croyez moi les smartphones à écran
pliable on en a beaucoup parlé on va
encore beaucoup en parler tout ça
vraiment hyper intéressant donc je vous
invite à faire une chose c'est à vous
abonner comme ça on en reparle très
prochainement et rassurez vous la
prochaine fois je me déconnecte aurait
pas comme ça je serai au fait de tous
voilà désolé
merci à vous merci de votre confiance à
très bientôt à deux matches